why are you called The Rock the birth
story of the rock is before I do what I
do now many moons ago I used to throw
around 300 pound men for a living and
get my ass kicked
that's it and then my original wrestling
name was Rocky my via which was a
combination of my dad's first name and
my grandfather's last name because both
of them were pro wrestlers and I hated
the name I hated it I hated it because
you hate it the lineage I had gave me
the opportunity yeah to at least knock
on the door you wanted your own space
in space while I was very proud to come
from who I came from with my dad and my
grandfather my whole family is in
wrestling uh a guy who was my father
figure and I've talked to you many times
about him Pat Patterson was a mentor of
mine in pro wrestling I lost him last
year when I lost my dad at the same time
I lost my father and my father figure on
the same year he said what did we call
you the rock as a french guy the tough
French accent I said I love it he goes
okay you're gonna rock